[موسيقى]
انا كنت اشتغل في شركه احنا خمسه اثنين
بدون اوراق
كل الشغل علي انا اروح احمل اولا ثانيه
صباح ثانيه صباح لكم لازم تكوني في
المستودع دنيا صباحا تحملش كل البضاعه
يعني 15 يوم وحدي وفي شغالين اخرين ثلاثه
مشتغلوش يعني الشغل كله
هذا المنطقه هذا تاع الانسان
[موسيقى]
في منطقه باريس ومحيطها هناك 22 في المئه
من السكان العاملين هم من المهاجرين وهي
نسبه عاليه جدا لاسيه ما عندما نقارنها مع
المناطق الفرنسيه الاخرى التي لديها نحو
اربعه في المئه فقط من العمال المهاجرين
وغالبا ما يشغلون كما هو الحاله هنا
متواضعه مقارنه ببقيه المهن الاخرى في
نسبه عاليه منهم يعملون في المساعده
المنزليه والطبخ واعمال البناء والحراسه
وفي هذه الوظائف في غالبا ما تكون ساعات
العمل متقطعه ويعمل فيها المهاجرون باعداد
اكبر من غير عمل المحدد
[موسيقى]
الاول شغل اشتغلته كان عمره شيء
بالخمسينات بعد كم يوم صار يسال اسئله
محرجه انا استغرب بعدين صار يحكي كلام
يعني غير مباشر
كلام مباشر
صار يقلل الادب كثير وصار يعني يعني يعرض
مبالغ يعني اليوم يعرض مبلغ وبكره بيزيد
عليه وبعده بيزيد عليه قول له انا مستحيل
انا جاي اشتغل ما بدي بعد فتره لما خلص
عرفت انه مستحيل راح اسوي هذا الشيء صار
علي بالشغل مثلا يضغط علي كثير يعني كثير
كان يضغط علي نفسيا
افوت على الشغل ببكي لما اطلع نفس الشيء
يعني لما وصلت معي لمرحله انه
حاولت
[موسيقى]